all of our experts tell us and they
advise the President as he endorsed
these guidelines to avoid social
gatherings of more than 10 people - if
you're sick stay home if if there's
someone in your home contracts the
coronavirus that everyone should stay
home as president Mike Pence right
they're encouraging Americans to follow
federal guidelines on the coronavirus
saying there will be tens of thousands
of tests in the next few days and weeks
and it is time for our headliner this
morning Kelly and Conway counselor to
the President and we should point out
that she sits in on some of those task
force meetings but it's not on the task
force Kelly Anne good morning to you and
welcome thank you I just came from there
and what and what do we need to know
well what you need to know is what the
president the vice-president the task
force have been saying the last few days
which is that these new guidelines from
the CDC will actually mitigate this
health crisis for many and literally
save lives so we all can do our part by
going to CDC gov Karuna virus gov look
at these guidelines the president self
has tweeted them out these are
unprecedented times with this virus and
it calls for unprecedented action but we
also know about the resilience and the
strength and the fortitude of the
American people we know that we're a
strong unified nation who will help the
elderly who can't get out for meals for
example the USDA just approved the
delivery of about roughly 1 million
meals a week to rural based students I
talked to secretary study Purdue at the
USDA and he in fact has this new email
feeding kids at USDA dot-gov that bill
that the Senate will vote on today that
the House passed last week does include
billions of dollars for nutritional
assistance for our own more populations
pregnant women women and with children
at the poverty line seniors children it
also includes billions of dollars for
vaccines and for paid family leave so
there are we can all do our best to
mitigate the health consequences of this
unprecedented virus but our government
is working together and with the private
sector to help mitigate the economic
devastation as well Kellyanne you just
teed up the Senate potentially acting
too
a Mitch McConnell short time ago saying
there will be a vote later today we
shall see on paid leave and the
unemployment insurance the other stuff
that the house had already passed but
the president has talked about dramatic
relief to the airline industry as well
something in the neighborhood of fifty
billion dollars how quickly do you think
the president and the Congress working
together can act on airline relief a
bigger package that Secretary of
missions been talking about as I
understand it the president just got off
the phone with some airline CEOs how did
that go that's right it did and and
you'll recall I think it was early last
week or so the president the vice
president also had the airline industry
representatives here at the White House
earlier the vice president went down to
Miami talked to the cruise line
representatives we keep on bringing
these different private sectors here and
now on the phone more and more because
of social distancing policies the
president is ready to act it really
depends on Congress but I know that
they're working together very well
secretary minuchin is in the lead with
the speaker and with leader McConnell
and others and we want to make sure that
we're bringing relief to those
industries and more importantly those
individuals whose economic wherewithal
is being disrupted through no fault of
their own because of this virus the
secretary secretary minuchin the
Secretary of Treasury yesterday broached
the idea of checks going to individuals
that will be means-tested so there's a
whole bunch of economic relief packages
being being undertaken we know that when
we say whole-of-government whole of
America approach that there are many
tools at the present disposal but more
importantly many tools at the disposal
the president and the Congress working
together reading from the president's
latest tweet here Kellyanne we will be
by mutual consent temporarily closing
our northern border with Canada to
non-essential traffic trade will not be
affected details to follow
that was the president one hour ago how
does how does he believe that that will
mitigate the spread of this virus for
the many of the same reasons the
president took early action to close
down the borders with China for example
travel going both ways and just last
week with Europe and then adding to that
list the UK and Ireland more recently
making very clear that cargo would not
be affected trade and commerce would not
be affected we are trying to this is not
punitive this is protection and if we're
asking Americans to change their
behaviors who also have to make sure
that we
our keeping ourselves on protected and
healthy here that is a mutual agreement
between Canon the US I know the
president has been speaking with them I
know he early on reached out to Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau about his wife
Sophie who has been diagnosed with a I
believe diagnosed with covin 19 or
undergoing a test and so we just
continue we want Americans to know that
we're in this together that we can all
do our part to mitigate the damage as
well but and just listening to these
briefings you know every cabinet agency
has a role to play
I think FEMA is a very familiar federal
government actor if you will
organization too many Americans they
usually see FEMA get ready for a weather
events that are being predicted for
example hurricanes and earthquakes in
this case they see FEMA being prepared
here I think that we're we want
Americans to understand - to replace
over panic with over preparedness nobody
should be upset if they're over prepared
or they over react to this kelly-ann we
have to wrap here but real quick the
president tweeted out that he's going to
have a news conference does that mean
he'll be there at 11:30 a.m. with the
task force or is he doing something else
this afternoon so stay tuned the task
force will have its daily briefing today
as you know for the last four
consecutive days the president has led
off he's been a part of that and he's
been there to take the questions also
and I think that transparency has been
wonderful for the public it's
information the president also is
looking to speak separately as he wishes
he uses his social media platform all
day long but he is very engaged in
wanting to speak directly to the public
I will end with this - we're very happy
to report that the major networks and
the cable stations radio have all
donated time for public service
announcements I want to thank everybody
out there for doing that the Vice
President and I have taken the lead on
that everyone has been tremendous these
are would-be competitors as
collaborators so that we make sure we're
getting that message to the American
people all at once hey Kelly um real
quick before you go is the president
been briefed on this 5.7 magnitude
earthquake and Utah the airport is
shutting down there's a ground stop
right now and the governor says that the
coronavirus hotline is down there's
closures they're assessing the damage he
is being briefed Sondra and I learned
about it as I came out of the Situation
Room from the task force briefing heard
for the first time we have no to mobile
devices in there so obviously the
presents being briefed I know that our
will do what we need to do to help Utah
through that crisis and I would remind
the people of Utah if even if your
hotline is down there are federal assets
in place that you can access you can go
to the website you can call the 188
number that FDA set up that FEMA has set
up that HHS has set up there are other
there are other means if you need
information all right Kellyanne Conway
at the White House will see the
president short time from now appreciate
it thank you